I want to give you another one of these
examples of Fox News casually mentioning
oh that story we covered for a week and
told you that we verified independently
turns out it was complete in total fake
news the latest is from Maria Bartiromo
this is the story Fox News ran with for
a week last week about supposed homeless
veterans being kicked out of hotels in
order to make room for undocumented
immigrants because of something Biden
did the story was totally made up Maria
Bartiromo waited an extra week before
casually updating us that the story was
completely made up we want to update you
on a report last week claiming that
Upstate hotels in Orange and Rockland
counties including the crossroads Hotel
Crossroads Hotel evicted a group of
homeless veterans we've since learned
that veterans Advocates misled local
officials and it now turns out those
eviction claims were false we want to
update you on the story make sure the
record was set straight and we'll get
more to you as we get it yeah there you
go what she mean means is it's fake news
we reported fake news and angered people
and fired people up based on a story
that's completely imaginary and remember
that Fox News said they verified the
story it's not well listen someone
reported this and we were misled they
claimed to have verified the story and
what it sounds like is going on is Fox
News lawyers have said you might want to
make a some kind of retraction about
this we did talk earlier this week of
Laura Ingram
um also casually mentioning by the way
that story was fake I
Eagles could move in turns out the group
behind the claim made it up
we have no clue as to why anyone would
do such a thing no we'll bring you any
updates should they come why would any
as I said on Monday why would anybody
lie in order to try to support their
pre-existing political narratives that
Biden is treating undocumented
immigrants quote better than Americans
and Veterans why would why would anyone
make that up and this was one other
retraction that was issued quick update
on a story from earlier this week about
homeless veterans being displaced from a
hotel in Newburgh New York right to make
room for migrants we're now looking into
new reports that a veterans Advocate
misled lawmakers about or and media
Outlets about a story that some homeless
men may have been hired to pose as
veterans we've reached out to the
organization for a statement but so far
have not heard back it's all so hazy we
just don't know what happened so there
is Maria Bartiromo shamelessly joining
those who say listen I don't know we
were misled wait you said you verified
the story that they don't mention
anymore
completely and totally pathetic we'll
see if any more retractions are coming
we have such a great bonus show for you
today that I hope that you're already a
member oh the bonus show where you want
to make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad we
will discuss on today's bonus show the
new study that finds 2 billion people
could be impacted by life-threatening
Heat by the end of the century we've
talked about heat before and I don't
mean Trump talking about applying light
and heat to cure I'm talking about heat
and climate change and the issues that
it will bring forward this new study is
very specific about where these
dangerous heat levels will be secondly
in Texas they are allowing unlicensed
religious chaplains to quote counsel
students as if they were therapists but
they are not this is the latest
placating of the uh religious
I don't even what to call you know what
to call them the sort of Christian
Sharia type folks in Texas we will
discuss it and U.S colleges are now
exploring
what would admissions look like if they
were no longer race conscious which is
we're talking about affirmative action
here this would be a major change in
American college admissions what would
it mean what would it do what would the
implications be all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show can't wait
for you to join us by simply signing up
at joinpakman.com